hi so i'm going to talk about almost
orthogonal basis for inner product
polynomials
my name is chris and this is a joint
work with aaron patechan from the
university of chicago
so this is a typical story about you an
up-and-coming computer scientist
and your function f
you'd like to get to know f better
well one way you can get to know f
better is by expressing f in the fourier
basis
so for example if f is a function on the
boolean hypercube say negative one plus
one raised to the n it takes real values
then to express f in the fourier basis
this just means writing it as a
multilinear polynomial in the inputs
so for example written at the bottom of
the slide here the both one function
takes in two inputs and checks whether
or not they are both one
then this is expansion as a multi-linear
polynomial
so for example if both of these inputs
are one then this will evaluate to one
and otherwise on any other boolean point
this will evaluate to zero
so why can you use the fourier basis to
get to know your function better
well in the fourier basis it's very easy
to read off a lot of properties of f
just by looking at the coefficients in
the basis for example you can easily
determine the variance of f or you can
determine the influence of each of the
individual input bits on the function f
a second property is that the basis is
orthonormal which is nice when the input
is random because the basis functions
are orthogonal under a random point from
the boolean hypercube
another nice property of the fourier
basis is that if you truncate the
fourier expansion to any fixed level
that gives you the optimal low degree
approximation for your function f which
is a nice property to have
finally the most compelling reason to
use the fourier basis is that it's an
awesome mathematical tool if you just
write your function f in the fourier
basis oftentimes your problem is just
instantly solved or at least becomes
simpler
furthermore the fourier basis technique
is also
applies to other domains other than just
the boolean hypercube so here you are
again and here is your function f now
applying to a different domain and here
are three different domains that you
might have in the first one
you have a function which is the input
comes from the integers mod n
in the second setting the input comes
from a standard gaussian random variable
and in the third setting the input is
uniformly chosen from the interval
between negative one and one
in all of these settings you might want
to express your function f in terms of a
north and normal basis on the input
domain
so in this first setting the orthonormal
basis that you should choose are the
fourier characters of zn
which i've written here written them
here on the slide they're these
exponentials
in the second setting when the input is
from a normal distribution the
orthonormal basis that you'd like to use
is the hermit polynomials
which are orthogonal when their input
comes from the standard normal
distribution
and in the third setting the orthonormal
basis that you could use is the legendre
polynomials li
and just to drive home how useful this
technique can be of decomposing your
function with respect to an orthonormal
basis i'll give you even more examples
so here are two more examples of f that
you might be studying
in the first example you again have a
function on the boolean hypercube
but now your function is additionally
constrained so that it only depends on
the hamming weight of the input vector x
so you'd like to express f with respect
to the handy ones as some function of
the hamming lines
well if x comes uniformly from the
hypercube
then the hamming weight of x is
distributed as a binomial random
variable
therefore
the orthogonal polynomial family that
you're interested in
is the orthogonal polynomials for the
binomial distribution
and these are well known and studied as
the quadric polynomials
the second example is due to distinct
neurofilnus and harsha
in this setting f is a function on a
high dimensional expander x
and specifically it assigns a real
number to each of the i dimensional
faces of the high dimensional expander
then you can give a harmonic
decomposition of f
so for example here it is um
f minus one will be a constant
and the other functions the higher
functions in the decomposition will have
mean zero
f zero assigns to each vertex of x a
real number
and then the higher functions have the
property that if you just average them
around the neighborhood of any vertex in
x then you get zero again
and so on for the higher degrees
so this example is a bit different from
the previous ones because we don't have
an explicit basis that we can represent
f in we only have ways to project f to
the different levels of the
decomposition
and there's actually another
technicality which is that it's not a
perfectly orthogonal decomposition it's
only approximately orthogonal
but hopefully these examples serve to
convince you of the utility of this
approach
okay in this last example you're a bit
sad because you don't know what is the
basis that you should be using for your
function f
so now your function takes in
vectors d1 through dm the inputs are d1
through dm and each gi is a
n-dimensional vector
which comes from a standard gaussian
distribution independent of each other
so for example here's a picture of what
the dis might be realized as
and furthermore this function f is
constrained to be orthogonally invariant
what that means is that for every
orthogonal matrix t if t is
simultaneously applied to the vectors d1
through dm
then the result of f does not change
what is an example of such an orthogonal
varying function
one example is measuring the angles
between the vectors
so
one could also measure the inner
products
so d1 d2
and if you multiply several of these
things together that's still going to be
orthogonal in variance
and we'll call such functions inner
product functions
for i guess as as we'll see they can be
expressed in terms of inner products of
the vectors d i's and t j's
so as i said you're a bit sad because
you don't know how to express your
function f
well fortunately this is where we come
in so our contribution is to give an
explicit almost orthogonal basis for
these inner product functions at least
in the case where they're polynomials
for inner product polynomials
so before i get to the basis first i
want to discuss the space a little more
and tell you why we were interested in
it
so
let f be a function
of d1 through dm these are vectors such
that f is orthogonally invariant and for
the rest of the talk we will assume that
f is a polynomial function of the
entries of the different vectors
so as i alluded to on the previous
slides it's not too hard to show that f
is a polynomial in the inner product
variables of d i with dj
so here's an example of a function f
that you might be considering for
example f is the inner product of d1 d2
times d2 d3 times d1 d3 minus 2 times d1
d2 squared e3 d3
so as you can see each of the terms in
the expansion of f corresponds with a
graph
on the vertex set 1 through m
and specifically an edge between i and j
corresponds to the inner product between
d i and dj
and in fact these correspond with multi
graphs as you can see in the example on
the right here uh d1 d2 squared means
there are two edges between one and two
and d3 d3 means there's a self loop at
three so in this way the
expansion the terms in the expansion of
f correspond exactly to multi graphs on
one through m
and we were interested in these
functions in the context of the sum of
squares algorithm in which we were
studying um functions of a collection of
random gaussian vectors
these functions might also be useful for
rounding algorithms or semi-definite
programs
because in that setting you're often
only interested in the angles between
vectors and not in the absolute
entries themselves
and we suspect these might also have to
do with multi-overlaps from statistical
physics
so just to get a little more comfort
with working with the space let me
compute the expectation of this function
f
so again the expectation is over the
vectors d i where each one is a uniform
is a standard gaussian and they're
chosen independently
and
i'll represent
for now as a type of as a graph that
we're taking the expectation over
so we have these two terms
and each of the inner products can be
expanded because it's just a sum of n
things
so
we sum over i j k
d 1 i
d 2 i
d 2 j d 3 j
d 1 k d 3 k
and similarly for the second term
so if you look at this expression
actually something nice happens most of
these terms have expectation zero
in fact the
only terms that won't have expectation
zero are the ones where the i's and js
match up so that every variable occurs
an even number of times
and the only way that can happen in the
first example is if i j k are all equal
and if that happens then you get
d1 i squared d2 i squared d3i squared
those are all uh equal to one because
the gaussian has variance one so in fact
this first term is just equal to n
because they're enter and non-zero turns
each of size one
in the second expression something
similar happens you must have i equals j
but then k is free to vary so actually
you get n squared here in this second
term
so actually just by thinking a little
bit harder about this example we'll
notice two interesting properties of
these inner product polynomials
let's say that i use mg to represent the
for a graph g but let it just be the
product over the edges of those inner
products so as we had here there were
two of them
then the expectation of one of these
terms is equal to zero if there exists a
vertex
of odd degree
in g
so the only way that a term can be
non-zero is if there's a way to pair up
all the i's j and k's meaning all the
vertices must have even degree
and furthermore we can determine the
magnitude of one of these terms
the magnitude of one of these terms is
given by
the max number of cycles
in a cycle decomposition of the graph g
that is
given that we can partition the edges of
g into cycles what's the maximum
possible number of cycles we can make
so actually this quantity is np hard to
compute in general from g
so this actually tells us a couple
interesting things about these
polynomials
first
it it's not likely that they have simple
expressions for things such as the
expectation or stuff like that because
these quantities are pretty hard to
determine so our goal is not to come up
with simple closed form expressions come
up
i guess available second point to make
is that the combinatorics of these
polynomials are intricately related to
the topology of the underlying graphs g
which is a really interesting feature
of the polynomial basis
so to expand a little bit more on what
was on the previous slide let's make the
definition so given a multi-graph g on m
we define mg to be the product over the
edges of the
inner product between t u and dv so just
the monomial represented by the graph g
then here's the lemma we prove
which is
a formula a concrete formula for the
expectation of mg it's the sum over
perfect matching
of n to the number of cycles in each
perfect matching collection
so what do these things mean
a perfect matching collection in a
multi-graph g is a perfect matching at
each vertex of the edges incident to
that vertex
so for example here i've depicted some
graph g the vertex labels aren't
important here's a graph g
one perfect matching collection would
pair up the incident edges at each
vertex so let me do that pairing now
this is one way you can do the pairing
and once you've made the pairing the
number of cycles
in the perfect matching collection
is just equal to the total number of
closed loops that you made
after doing all the pairing so
here we have
that's one loop and we have a second
loop like this
so the number of cycles in this
particular matching is two
so the formula says that we need to sum
over all perfect matching collections of
n raised to the number of cycles
in the perfect matching collection
to do an example suppose we are working
with the cycle graph
which is just the inner product of a
bunch of vectors in a cycle
then
in any perfect matching collection
there's actually only one group of
matching collection because each vertex
only has degree two you have to pair
them up like this
just each pair pairs up
and
now there's only one cycle in this total
perfect matching collection so
expected value of mg is always n for the
cycle
let me do one more example here
so let's say that mg is this slightly
larger graph which is these inner
products
and to compute the expectation of mg we
need to sum over all
perfect matching collections ing
so what are the possible ways that we
can form these perfect matching
collections well at vertex 1
you know exactly how you must pair up
incident edges same with vertex 3 they
must pair like this
for vertex 2 there are three possible
ways to do it so let me draw those three
possible ways
and one and three are the same
and two you could either pair them like
this
like this
or like this
in this first case there are two loops
formed by the perfect match collection
so you get a factor of n squared in the
second case there's only one loop in the
second case there's also only one loop
so in total the total is the sum of
these things it's just n squared plus 2n
so again this gives an exponential
formula for the expectation of mg
over some sort of combinatorial objects
in the graph
so now that we've studied that a bit
more it's time to move on to the actual
basis for the functions in this space so
let's say that f is some polynomial in
the new products and it has total degree
at most capital d
the basis we'll write it as pg
where g is a multi-graph on one through
m with at most d h's
the basis function pg will have a unique
leaving monomial mg
and the degree of pg therefore is just
equal to the degree of mg
and that's equal to the number of edges
in the graph g
the pg will satisfy the following
orthogonality property
if the degrees are not equal
then they're orthogonal
in fact they actually have a slightly
stronger orthogonality property which is
that if the graph degree of a particular
vertex
is not equal
then the polynomials are also
so this is what we mean when we say that
the polynomials are almost orthogonal
and they furthermore one one other
orthogonality property which is if you
compute the expectation of pg and ph
then
it's actually guaranteed to be small as
long as g and h are not different
it's significantly less than the square
root of the variance
so this is the property that the basis
will have
so what is the formula for the basis
well here it is
so we define pg to be a sum over
matching collections in the graph g
of
the monomial for the rounded graph of
the matching collection m
times a sine which is just negative one
raised to the number of things matched
times what we've seen before n to the
number of cycles in the matchy
collection
okay so the difference with the previous
formula is that these are no longer
perfect matching collections they're
just matching collections so at each
vertex we match up incident edges but
you no longer have to pair everything
you can choose a subset of the incident
edges to match
for example here i have drawn this graph
g
one way you could do it is you could
match up this
incident edge here like this and you can
leave these other two unmatched at red
vertex match up this one here you can
match up these here
this is one possible way you can form a
matching collection in this graph
okay the routed graph is the result of
following the matching collections and
forming a new graph we've replaced all
the
edges by their completely routed
versions
so this edge which previously started at
this vertex if you follow it through the
matching collections it now becomes an
edge that goes all the way to that of it
and this
edge here now becomes a stealth loop
because that's what happens when you
route it using the matching collection n
so this is the routed
graph m
so let me give an example of the
polynomial for this particular graph g
uh d1 d2 squared
in this graph there are four possible
matching collections let me draw them
the first matching collection is
does nothing it does not match any of
the
any of the incident edges at any of the
vertices the second one matches at one
second the third one matches a two and
the fourth one matches f of one and two
so okay let's work out what the term is
for this
the m sub route here is going to be d1
d2 squared
and the
sine is going to be just one because we
did not the size of m is zero
and
the the number of closed cycles in n is
zero so cycles of n measures the number
of closed cycles
for this second term
the routed graph looks like d2 d2
the sign is negative one because we
matched one thing and there are no
closed cycles so again this is one
third example we have d1 d1 for the
routed graph
negative one for the sign and again one
because there are no closed cycles
in this last graph the rounded graph is
the trivial graph with no edges so
that's one
the sign is negative one squared and the
number of cycles is one so we get a
factor of n
so
overall the orthogonal polynomial for
this graph is d1 d2 squared
minus d1 d1
minus d2 d2
plus n
okay so that's the definition of the
orthogonal columns
so we also define orthogonal polynomial
bases for inputs coming from other
distributions
when they're not necessarily gaussian
and the two cases that we consider are
when the dis are uniform unit vectors
chosen from the unit sphere and
dimensions
and when they're uniformly chosen from
the hypercube in dimensions
uh we're not able to work with general
input distributions but we are able to
give somewhat clean formulas for these
two settings in addition to the gaussian
setting and they have a similar spirits
where again we're summing over
exponentially matching exponentially
many matches in an underlying graph and
again this is the basis for orthogonal
functions orthogonally symmetric
functions on these spaces so i want to
go into each of these two regimes a
little bit more
so first we'll start with the spherical
setting
in which the di's are independently
chosen from the unit sphere and we're
looking at functions which just measure
like angles between the di's
the orthogonal polynomials pg that we
get
come from the so-called maxwell
representation of the spherical
harmonics
you may have heard of the spherical
harmonics before and you might know that
they are kind of a pain to work with but
if you use the maxwell representation of
spherical harmonics then this is
actually fairly simple because it's just
a degree orthogonal
um represent basis for functions on the
sphere and they're very similar to the
herme polynomials and for that reason
they the expressions actually look very
similar to expressions in the gaussian
setting
so again we get similar formulas based
on matchings in an underlying graph of
inner products but they're slightly
harder
and an interesting feature of the
spherical setting is that the
combinatorics of the graph
of these polynomials seems to be related
to planarity properties of the graphs gh
which is really surprising that there's
a connection between the unit sphere and
planar graphs
so just to illustrate something strange
in the gaussian setting it's true that
for every graphs every pair of graphs g
and h
the expectation of pg times ph is always
non-negative
often it's zero but if it's not zero
it's always positive in spherical
setting that's not the case
so for example if you take k5 and you
break it up into two five cycles as
depicted here one in blue and one in red
if you take the orthogonal polynomials
for the uh
to the two five cycles and you take
their expectation then that actually is
negative
and this is the smallest example
with this property there are other
examples with the k5 minor that also
have negative we don't know anything
based on k-3 at the moment but certainly
this is a strange property that these
polynomials seem to have
okay in the boolean setting uh we
consider when the di are uniform from
the boolean hypercube
and okay watch as you clarify what is
the function space now
it's under it's the space of functions
of these vectors d one b m which are
invariant under orthogonal
transformations that preserve the
hypercube that is there it's invariant
under automorphisms of a hypercube
what is
what are the automorphisms of the
hypercube
so there are two types the first is a
bit flip
where you flip the bits by some z
and the second is a permutation of the
coordinates where you apply some
permutation pi on the coordinates of the
input
so we are considering functions which
are invariant under these automotives of
the cube
and one should ask
in the spherical and gaussian settings
we knew what the non-orthogonal basis
was formed by it was formed by inner
product expressions
what are the non what's the basis for
functions of this type anyway
a basis for functions of this type
it comes from generalizing inner
products to expressions of this
form
so this
measures given an even number of vectors
to sum up the coordinates of the vector
of the vectors multiplied together
for example if k equals one
then this is just taking the inner
product between d i and d j
or k equals two this is doing some sort
of like higher order inner product where
you measure the
inner product between four different
vectors
so the result is that we construct a set
of polynomials pg
where each g is now a hyper graph on one
through n and in fact it's an even hyper
graph meaning that all of the hyper
edges have even size of either two four
six b whatever when they're two they
correspond to normal inner products when
you're higher than that they correspond
to these generalization products
and it seems like the combinatorics of
this setting combines some of the
aspects of the gaussian and spherical
cases
on the one hand the vectors
all lie on a sphere they all have some
fixed norm therefore you don't have self
loops in the graph which is a feature of
the spherical setting
on the other hand
the boolean setting doesn't seem to
exhibit a connection to primarily like
the spherical setting
and in that way it seems a little bit
more gaussian
so in conclusion we presented explicit
degree orthogonal basis
for orthogonally invariant functions of
a collection of random vectors
and we studied three different regimes
or settings in which the random vectors
could come from
the gaussian setting the
unit sphere and also the boolean
hypercube
and we saw that the combinatorics of
these bases is really intricately
connected to the topology of the
underlying graphs
so we're still looking for applications
of these bases
it would be really cool to exploit the
interesting combinatorics of these
polynomials in order to prove something
really interesting about
these orthogonally invariant functions
so now that you've watched this video i
hope you're prepared to do just that
thanks for watching